Arkansas State Police are looking for
the cause of a bus crash that killed a
nine-year-old boy nearly 50 passengers
most of them children were hurt when the
charter bus flipped Monday morning on
Interstate 30 near Little Rock it was
taking youth football players home to
Memphis after a championship tournament
in Dallas
Omar Villafranca is in Little Rock Omar
good morning good morning we learned the
bus drivers name is EULA Jarrett and
that most of the passengers on her bus
were in elementary school there's still
four kids here at Arkansas Children's
Hospital and one of the passengers on
the bus told us he felt the bus swerved
and then violently rolled I woke up when
I liked a lot of screaming and the
coaches were trying to keep everybody
calm
tied jeer Terrell is one of at least 26
children some he says as young as six
years old who were injured when their
charter bus ran off this highway ramp
the 13-year old walked away with 18
stitches in his head and a bruise around
his left eye so he under side thought I
was gonna die and we lost one the crash
killed nine year old Cameron Johnson
Taiji's mother Deidre Terrell used to
take care of Cameron he was a joy dr.
Todd Maxon says the flood of patients
filled the ER at Arkansas Children's
Hospital the injuries have ranged really
from injuries to the skull and brain to
lots of lacerations lots of broken bones
Arkansas State Police say the bus driver
told them she lost control of the
vehicle causing it to roll the charter
bus company that owns the bus
tennessee-based scott shuttle service
received federal regulators highest
safety rating the business was fined in
July for allowing the driver to operate
one of its vehicles without a proper
license a lot of them never had the
opportunity to leave Memphis JT Bragg
oov is one of several coaches and
parents who raised over a hundred miles
from Memphis to Little Rock to help care
for the injured children it was a huge
trip for these kids in the
a complete tragedy the bus company has
not responded to our request for
comments we don't know if there were
seatbelts on the bus but we do know
there was a black box and that's where
investigators hope to learn a little bit
more about the crash as for the four
kids still at the hospital doctors say
they're expected to make a full recovery
John Omar thank you